nests please come on stage you're good
so we have just seen you in the movie
also you're using Internet a lot so what
are you using internet for at home well
I used to internet for a lot of things
such as again searching up homework
texting with my friends skyping with my
friends facetiming with my friends and a
whole lot more okay thanks when you're
living in Switzerland and then you're
using internet at home so how is your
internet so they they they speed how can
you work with internet I don't know
which term T is horrible or terrible
okay I'll use terrible okay
Jeanette connection at home is terrible
it never connects to the internet with
my laptop never connects to the internet
and I have to go through a lot of things
to get it back home working okay thanks
so sounds doesn't sound too amber they
are too too exciting but for example if
there would be Christmas or your purse
they were wish day so you think about
the future of Internet or how Internet
should be so so so what what do you say
then oh well I want the Internet to be
as fast as a cheetah because right now
it's slower than a snail well I would
like there to be little internet mobile
internet rooms in each local areas such
as cafes and train stations so but to
prevent that from happening
like little blogs happening we also need
lot longer internet connection so from
point A to B it should be flawlessly
perfect internet connection okay nice
thanks a lot you stay with us here on
stage so next she will be one of our
future customers